so what we have depicted here we have a
block and let's say that this block is
completely stationary and it's being
pushed up against this non frictionless
wall so this wall does have friction
with the block it's being pushed by this
force of magnitude F and its direction
makes an angle of theta with the
horizontal what I want you to do is
pause this video and construct a
Freebody diagram for this block include
the vertical and horizontal components
of this force right over here but also
include other things include the force
include the force of gravity acting on
this block include the force of friction
acting on this block and include the
normal force of the wall acting on the
block as well pause the video and try to
have a go at it
so before I even start to draw the
Freebody diagram let's break down this
force into its vertical and horizontal
components so the first thing let me do
its vertical component so it would look
like that and it's horizontal component
would look like this and so what's the
magnitude of the vertical component well
it is opposite this angle that we know
this is the angle that is Theta and so
this is going to be the vertical
component is going to be F sine of theta
we've seen that in previous videos and
it comes straight out of right triangle
trigonometry encourage you to review
that if this looks unfamiliar and the
magnitude of the horizontal component
that is going to be F cosine theta this
side right over here is adjacent to the
angle
sokka Toa and now with that out of the
way we can draw our Freebody diagram
so let me draw that Freebody let me draw
that block and I'm really just going to
focus on the block only and we know a
couple of things that are going on we
know that we have this horizontal force
F cosine theta so let me draw that so
the magnitude there is F cosine theta we
know we have this vertical force F sine
theta so let me draw that so this would
be f and that one's actually a little
bit shorter
it's obviously not drawn perfectly to
scale but this would be F sine theta and
now let's think about these characters
right over here we have the force of
gravity and so that's going to be acting
downward so it would look something like
this so we have and it would have
magnitude F sub G I'm not drawing the
arrow now cuz I'm just talking about the
magnitude of this vector here I'm
referring to the entire vector I'm
referring to its magnitude and direction
now what about the force of friction and
let's assume we're in a situation where
the magnitude of the vertical component
of this applied force F sine theta is
less than the magnitude of the force of
gravity well in that situation if there
was no friction the block would start
accelerating downward because you would
have a net force downward we haven't
talked about the forces to the left and
right yet but as we mentioned this thing
is stationary and the force of friction
is going to act against the direction of
motion and so in this situation the
force of friction will act upwards and
so we would have a force of friction
just like that and its magnitude would
be F sub lowercase F and then last but
not least what about the normal force
well if this block is not accelerating
in any direction that means that the
normal force must perfectly counteract
this force to the right which is the
horizontal component of this applied
force and so our normal force is going
to go to the left and it would look like
this so it's magnitude is F sub capital
n so there you have it we have drawn a
Freebody diagram for this scenario right
over here if these two were equal then
you would have no force of friction or
the force of friction would be zero it
would there'd be nothing for it to be
counteracting these two would perfectly
cancel out
and if the magnitude of the vertical
component of the applied force were
greater than the force of gravity
without friction it would start to
accelerate upwards and so the force of
friction would act against that motion
but let's just go with this scenario
right over here and start to appreciate
why Freebody diagrams are so useful
because we could start to set up
equations that relate these magnitudes
we could say look if this box is not
accelerating in any way if there's zero
net forces in the horizontal and the
vertical directions well then we could
say that F sub n completely counteracts
F times cosine of theta so we could say
F sub n is equal to is equal to F cosine
theta and we could also say that F sine
theta F sine theta plus the magnitude of
the force of friction plus the magnitude
of the force of friction that these
would completely counteract the
magnitude of the force of gravity
because it's going in the opposite
direction so these would be equal to F
sub G and so once you set up equations
like this if you know all but one of
these variables you can figure out the
other ones which is very useful in
physics